kernkraft oder kohle das ist die
wichtigste frage aktuell in deutschland
eher kernkraft oder kohle mit welcher
energie kommen wir sicher über den
winter brauchen wir die kernkraft zurück
wenn putins gas und öl dann weg sind ja
die frage haben wir den ministern
gestellt kernkraft oder kohle und das
haben wir vor allen dingen die grünen
minister gefragt zb die grüne
umweltministerin noch mal ganz kurz zur
erinnerung ende dieses jahres geht das
letzte deutsche atomkraftwerk vom netz
steffi lemke was sagt sie jetzt darauf
auf kernkraft oder kohle sie ist sehr
schmallippig und antwortet nur zur zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt zur atomdebatte
nichts hinzufügen zu wollen und alle
anderen grünen minister verweisen
einfach auf robert habeck der im moment
aber auch sagt debatte erledigt
brennstäbe lieferung dauert zu lange das
haben wir geprüft und da ist der stempel
drauf fertig abgeschlossen jetzt schauen
wir aber mal im gegensatz zu den grünen
auf den koalitionspartner was macht die
fdp also von verkehrsminister volker
wissing als auch finanzminister
christian lindner die antworten hier zb
volker wissing der sagt in der
notsituation und angesichts des
klimawandels darf man sich neuen denken
nicht verschließen deshalb bin ich für
eine ideologie ideologiefreie prüfung
offen also zumindest für die prüfung
offen ja und ganz ähnlich auch der
finanzminister ebenfalls fdp christian
entspricht eben auch davon dass in der
drohne notsituation nochmal eine solche
ideologiefreie prüfung stattfinden muss
also die fdp möchte diese debatte traut
sich noch nicht so richtig weil die
grünen die debatte gar nicht freuen aber
das ist die diskussion dieses tages
kernkraft oder kohle sie wird geführt am
tag der industrie diese redeschlacht
heute und da mischt sich natürlich auch
die opposition ein auch markus söder
bayerns ministerpräsident sagt zur frage
kohle oder kernkraft das
fakt ist doch dass das argument ist
seien keine brennstäbe einsetzbar
fachlicher blödsinn ist denn sie sind
überall in der welt sind sie besorgt
alle europäischen nachbarn machen das
war unklaren wir dass wir schlauer und
bis das sind
ja dass also der kommentar aus bayern
und wir begrüssen jetzt in energie und
sicherheitsexperten frank umbach von der
universität in bonn schönen guten tag
ihnen darunter mit welcher
energiesicherheit gehen wir in diesem
winter
also habe ich hat ja eigentlich selber
gesagt wir müssen jede kilowattstunde
einsparen und das heißt eben das wenn
der tat ideologiefrei an diese fragen
herangehen müssen und jede option
eigentlich nehmen müssen wir im moment
haben wir eine situation wo die
gaskraftwerken noch auf vollen touren
für die stromproduktion laufen das hätte
eigentlich vor wochen schon umgestellt
werden müssen um sicher zu gehen dass
die gasspeicher entsprechend gefüllt
werden und deswegen stellt sich für mich
nicht unbedingt die frage kohle oder
kernkraft sondern es ist eher eine
antwort im sinnes des sowohl-als-auch
und im übrigen darf dürfen wir auch
nicht vergessen wir haben in deutschland
durchaus ja immer noch eigene schiefer
gas
reserven in einem umfang die 30 jahre
den gasverbrauch in deutschland
entsprechend versorgen können und wir
führen eine diskussion dass wir
flüssiggas aus den usa als schiefergas
ja einführen während wir in deutschland
diese option mit vermeintlichen
umweltrisiken die vor zehn jahren
bereits widerlegt worden sind
wissenschaftlich verhindern wollen wenn
wir flüssiggas beispielsweise auch bei
wird ihr schiefergas auch bei uns
fördern würden wir das im übrigen einen
beitrag zum globalen klimaschutz weil
wenn wir selber fördern wir deutlich
weniger co2 und methan gas verbrauchen
würden als wenn wir das importieren
würden als auch hier gb aktion aber auch
hier gibt es sozusagen diese ideologie
diskussion also kohle und kernkraft sagt
frank umbach dann aber nach dem gas auch
nach dem schiefergas nochmal ganz
fokussiert auf die kernkraft da kommt ja
immer das argument ja das haben wir
geprüft das dauert mit der lieferung der
brennstäbe einfach zu lange ist nicht
ehrlich halten sie was dagegen oder
stimmt das
nein wenn man sich rechtzeitig natürlich
darum gekümmert hätte dann wäre dieses
problem mit den brennstäben natürlich
schon längst gelöst aber man hat ja
diese diskussion seit wochen
aufgeschoben obwohl er sehr viele
technikexperten ja auch schon darauf
hingewiesen haben dass es auch keine
sicherheitsbedenken gibt denn wir haben
ja auch in deutschland eigentlich die
sichersten kernkraftwerke der welt immer
noch die nach 2011 ja auch getestet
worden sind von der eu weit und er hat
sich auch herausgestellt eben dass alle
kernkraftwerke um uns herum in berg in
frankreich slowakei alle unsicherer sind
und das argument der brennstäbe hätte
schon längst gelöst werden können ist
prinzipiell kein problem sondern ist
hängt hier an dem politischen willen
weil es natürlich an den kern der grünen
partei gehe aus einer anti nuklear
bewegung ja mal entstanden ist sagt
frank umbach energie experte von der
universität bonn vielen herzlichen dank
für ihre einschätzungen ja
und wir sprechen weiter über dieses
thema hier im studio jetzt unser bild
politik chef hans schäfer schönen guten
tag hallo also man ist sich völlig einig
aber noch nicht in der politik
eigentlich sagen alle experten kernkraft
hier sogar gehört kohle und kernkraft
müssen wir vorantreiben warum stellt
sich die politik so quer oder es schafft
es einfach nicht dort voranzukommen
kernkraft woher kommt diese angst noch
davor das ist eine ganz alte ich glaube
das hat frank umbach den wir gerade im
interview gesehen haben sehr gut gesagt
die die regierung besteht aus spd fdp
und den grünen und die grünen haben in
ihrer dna das anti atomkraft das anti
akw gehen da geht nichts und das ist das
ist entscheidend für die grünen deswegen
hat auch beispielsweise die prüfung ob
wir kernkraftwerke länger laufen lassen
können oder nicht gerade mal 48 stunden
gedauert also es gab eigentlich keine
richtige prüfung robert habeck und
steffi lemke haben sie einfach die köpfe
zusammengesteckt gesagt lassen wir die
kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen nein das
können wir nicht dann gab es ein vermerk
der wahl auch ungefähr 48 stunden
geschrieben das ist eigentlich
bemerkenswert wenn wir es doch mit einer
so großen krise zu tun haben das
eigentlich in st zeitwert von zwei tagen
die regierung oder zwei minister
entscheiden machen wir nicht und jetzt
sehen wir dass es in der regierung aber
doch andere positionen auch gibt die fdp
ist da deutlich offener und man muss
sich den strommix vielleicht von heute
nacht einmal anschauen und da sehen wir
dass die kernkraft noch zu fast sechs
prozent zur stromerzeugung beigetragen
hat heute nacht gas aber beispielsweise
zu rund zwölf prozent bedeutet wenn man
gas rausnehmen würde weil man es
beispielsweise für die für das auffüllen
von speichern braucht dann hätte man
natürlich eine lücke die man
beispielsweise dann mit der kernkraft
auch teilweise füllen könnte wenn man
die kernkraft auch nach rausnehmen würde
bräuchte man acht wie wie der zu heute
dann automatisch mehr gas und das ist
das dilemma in dem wir uns befinden eine
klare antwort ja oder nein weil ich bei
der bundesregierung seit wochen
eigentlich auf diese antwort warte sind
wir stand jetzt stand heute mit blick
auf den herbst und winter energie sicher
in deutschland wenn wir von energie
sprechen die wir nur in deutschland
selbst herstellen würde ich sagen nein
jetzt wird das das große thema seien
heute tag der deutschen industrie eine
redeschlacht dort um unser gas um unsere
energie um unseren strom der kanzler der
oppositionsführer der finanzminister der
wirtschaftsminister auf wen wächst der
druck jetzt auf habeck und scholz
nachzugeben in sachen kernkraft oder auf
lindner das mit der kernkraft ein für
alle mal tatsächlich sein zu lassen am
ende ist es natürlich der kanzler dass
es ganz klar er führt diese regierung
und er führt zurzeit auch eine regierung
die auf einem anti atomkraft kurs ist
und wenn wir es dann im herbst und im
winter mit möglicherweise energie
ausfällen zu tun haben wenn viele firmen
vielleicht auch nicht mehr richtig
produzieren können weil ihnen
beispielsweise das gas fehlt oder weil
einfach nicht genug strom da ist oder
die strompreise auch noch mal extrem
steigen dann wird das am ende vollkommen
zu recht auch beim bundeskanzler
abgeladen er ist derjenige der da am
stärksten unter druck steht und
friedrich merz kann da aus einer ganz
anderen position auf spielen aus einer
des treibers natürlich aus der
oppositionsrolle heraus spielte diese
position natürlich auch ganz stark
schmid aus dem kanzler natürlich auch
immer wieder auf's brot für wii
wahrscheinlich hälst du da einen
kurswechsel es ist ja eine wirklich
schwierige gemengelage die fdp fdp dies
weiterhin versucht und spd und grüne die
weiterhin zurückhaltend sind beide
müssen entscheidung getroffen werden
olaf scholz hat in einem interview
gestern gesagt dass er im prinzip offen
wäre wenn es denn technisch möglich wäre
die kernkraftwerke die letzten drei
meiler auch über 20 22 hinauslaufen zu
lassen so und jetzt ist heute der
kernkraft verband zu wort gekommen
münchner merkur und der hat auch noch
mal gesagt ja wir können uran brennstäbe
besorgen das geht wir müssen uns jetzt
bloß zügig entscheiden man könnte zum
beispiel brennstäbe aus australien
importiert das ist technisch offenbar
möglich wir haben es auch gerade gehört
von frank umbach der gesagt hat die
deutschen kernkraftwerke sind weiterhin
die sichersten der welt war ja auch
immer argumentiert wird man müsste jetzt
noch sicherheitsüberprüfung machen das
würde alles gar nicht gehen also der
stand ist zurzeit so ein weiterbetrieb
wäre möglich man müsste sich bloß
schnell entscheiden denn man braucht
natürlich die brennstäbe dann wäre die
energie möglicherweise sicher und den
grünen würde laden auseinander fliegen
zumindest vorübergehend danke an
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer